madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
membres du gouvernement mesdames et
messieurs les députés mes chers
collègues
horreur
sidération
angoisse le monde est aujourd'hui en
état de choc devant la violence de
l'attaque terroriste qui a frappé
Israël devant cette barbarie
je veux redire ici qu'Israël est un pays
ami à qui je veux réaffirmer au nom de
la représentation
nationale notre totale solidarité et
notre soutien
inconditionnel
à
l'heure à l'heure où nous parlons les
combats se poursuivent et le nombre des
victimes ne cesse de
s'alourdir nous pleurons également la
mort de quatre de nos compatriotes et
sommes t jours sans nouvelle de 13
d'entre
eux rien ne justifie ni ne justifiera
jamais le
terrorisme aucune cause n'autorise à
tirer sur des civils à enlever des
enfants à utiliser des otages comme
bouclier humain partout sous toutes ses
formes et sous tous ces prétextes le
terrorisme doit être condamné et
combattu sans ambigué et sans la moindre
nuance attenté à un pays démocratique s
attaqué toutes les démocraties du monde
attenter aux populations civiles c'est
menacer l'humanité
entière en hommage aux victimes en signe
de solidarité avec leurs familles comme
avec celles qui sont sans nouvell de
personnes prises en otage porter disparu
je vous demande mesdames et messieurs
les membres du gouvernement mesdames et
messieurs les députés de bien vouloir
observer une minute de
silence
je vous remercie